Російський ексклав на Балтійському морі
Калінінград готується зустрічати чемпіонат світу з футболу.
Рекламні щити, символіка чемпіонату, і, звичайно, новий стадіон.
Ця величезна конструкція, яка вміщує 35 тисяч людей виросла ... на болоті.
Місце її будівництва від самого початку викликало багато суперечок.
Воно складне саме по собі з точки зору будівництва.
Але сьогодні вже всі будівельні роботи позаду і можна сказати,
що місця кращого важко навіть собі уявити і придумати.
Місцева влада пишається такою підготовкою до мундіалю.
Однак екологи кажуть про шкоду довкіллю.
Адже лише щоб розпочати будівельні роботи
знадобилися тисячі паль і мільйони тон піску.
Це типовий дельтовий острів, який утворюється в дельті річки.
Намивний ... з такими торф'янистими болотистими ґрунтами
і порослим очеретом.
Взагалі-то це був такий, райський куточок в місті,
де мешкали птахи.
У підсумку "райський куточок" виявився штучно
засипаним шестиметровим шаром піску,
що призвело до втрати водно-болотяної екосистеми.
Крім того, до будівництва стадіону болотистий острів Ломза
служив природним фільтром для забрудненої стоками річки Преголя.
Гирло річки Преголя дуже сильно забруднене.
Тому їй, звичайно потрібен, кожен фільтр,
кожна можливість очищатися.
А відомо, що болотисті очеретяні зарості служать фільтром.
Думки жителів з приводу нового стадіону теж розділилися.
Одні радіють розвитку міста, інші не впевнені
у безпеці престижного об'єкта.
Там було раніше щось на зразок болота.
І мені здається, що воно почне з часом просідати
і стадіон почне розвалюватися.
Загалом будівництво стадіону обійшлося майже у 300 мільйонів доларів.
Задовго до чемпіонату світу стадіон став
рекордсменом за видатками бюджету.
На освоєння лише прилеглої до стадіону території
з бюджету РФ витратили майже 32 мільйони доларів.
Більша частина цих грошей пішла ... у пісок.